vous pensez que vous êtes plus
intelligent que lui vous pensez que vous
êtes celui qui va le pousser à ce
confesser je ne pense pas être plus
intelligent monsieur je ne pense pas
qu'il soit nécessaire d'être plus
intelligent que lui voilà comment ça va
se passer il va vous parler il va jouer
avec vous pendant un moment votre fils
sait ce que vous faites il sait que son
papa protège les gens il va jouer au
chat et à la souris avec vous il va vous
faire croire que vous progressez avec
lui bien appuyé sur le bouton et
commençons notre discussion
nous sommes le 13 février 1986 je suis
l'agent billagmeyer et je suis avec
Théodore je suis avec Ted Bundy
n'a plus que 13h à vivre et il les
utilise pour essayer de gagner du temps
il est prêt à parler il est enfin prêt à
tout avouer mais il ne veut parler qu'à
une seule personne il y a des familles
qui cherchent des réponses le monde doit
savoir pourquoi il a tué ses filles vous
êtes une jeune star montante et je suis
votre prochaine grande affaire vous êtes
le gars qui va me briser
il y a beaucoup de mythes et de
malentendus à mon sujet
de quoi allez-vous me parler de
tout tu penses qu'il veut quoi vous et
moi on va se poser et on va avoir la
conversation que vous vouliez avoir
depuis le début si tu te rapproches trop
d'un gars comme lui tu peux perdre ton
chemin pensez-vous pourriez tuer
quelqu'un je suis un agent du FBI je ne
parle pas de ça
vous ne pouvez pas prendre ces filles en
ne Ta jeune joue à rien là combien vous
en avez tué disons 30 et si on parlait
du nombre réel 30 est un joli nombres
vous imissez dans ma tête je cherche
juste à comprendre vos pensées qu'il
devrait me tuer ma vraie vous pensez
qu'il est temps pour moi de mourir
franchement ils auraient probablement dû
le faire il y a longtemps je vais vous
emmener quelque part je n'ai jamais
encore emmené personne
[Musique]
j'ai besoin d'un moment avec Mila il est
mon meilleur ami